so humility
manifests itself in economics as the
belief in a free market meaning like i
can't centralize i can't do centralized
control on this thing
we're going to uh minimize the friction
of the free exchange of goods
so um austrian economics puts priority
in in the market
yes and you could you could you could
arrive at it through two paths the the
the more um
the more practical path which most
scientific minded people arrive at you
know i came from an engineering
background so i initially had this idea
that
what is lacking in economics is
mathematicization we need to have better
math models we need to get all those
tools from engineering apply them to
economics and then we'll be able to plan
the world economy and make it work
better and then you start actually
trying to solve problems you know to try
and actually calculate them and you
realize nobody can have that ability
because the difference ultimately comes
down to the fact
we can't have experiments and the reason
we can't have experiments is that you
can experiment on particles of a gas you
can experiment on human beings on entire
economies
and because
particles of a gas are just dumb matter
and so you know you you kick matter in a
certain way you can calculate exactly
how much is going to fly human beings
are much more complex they have a will
inside them and this is really
the this is the humility to understand
that you are a human being and other
people are also a human being just like
you
and that
the the you know every person wakes up
every morning and they have a million
things in their mind a million things
they care about a million things they
want to do
and
you will never be able to make the
decisions for somebody else let alone
for millions of other people so this is
one path by which you arrive at the
conclusion that free markets are better
because you realize that all the people
that think that they can centrally plan
markets
can't actually do that
and that there's really
nothing scientific about them except
essentially the rituals they ape of the
scientific process and the other path i
think that iran makes you arrive at the
austrian
perspective or the libertarian
perspective i should say
is um
simply the the the notion of individuals
as having their own inalienable right to
decide what they want to do with
themselves if you
i mean the only way that you can give
yourself the idea that
you get to be planner
is ultimately you think you're better
than other people you think your choice
your judgment overrides mine
and i don't think that's a defensible
position i think
i'm in no position to want to force
anybody ever i will never want to force
anybody to do anything they don't want
um the keynesian perspective the central
planning perspective is
unlike physics you know which is let's
force a bunch of particles to sit in the
lab so that we can study them
in economics you're forcing people to do
things you know that's stop these people
from doing this job because it's bad for
the economy and let's get them to do
that job let's force them to pay this
price let's tax them this much let's
prevent them from using gold as money
and force them to use our credit as
money so it has to rely on coercion
there's no central planning without
coercion and coercion is
a crime in my opinion there's no way
that it is justifiable morally or from
our politics from an ethical perspective
uh your view is the i mean perhaps the
broadly speaking of the libertarian view
is
coercion
is unethical
freedom is essential
what is what are the pros and cons of
government intervention in the economy
so can you steal man can you provide
pros you just kind of provided arguments
against
is there any arguments to be made for
government intervention for the role of
government in society speaking from a
political or from an economics
perspective what is a positive role of
government
that you could imagine you can speak to
i can repeat many other cases but i i
don't find any of them compelling for
the reason that i mentioned which is
that ultimately they all rely on putting
a gun to somebody's head and using the
threat of force so that's for me it can
never be justifiable whatever the ends
are
if the means are
violence and
the threat of violence then the ends
aren't justified everything that's good
governments will use as an excuse to
justify coercion
so you know what do you like you like
motherhood and apple pie well government
needs to ensure that motherhood works
well and we need government central
planning of birth we need regulations on
birth for instance we need regulations
on uh how people give birth we need to
ban people from giving birth in
traditional ways that have been tried
for thousands of years we need to force
people to do things in the modern
scientific way well so what about things
like
that all of us use so infrastructure for
example or education
um
or well the economy too right uh
can you make a case for the role of
some
large-scale centralized systems whether
it's government or not that do this kind
of management i guess perhaps you could
say there's the economies of scale
argument that some things must exist at
a very hard a very large scale and
therefore you would want
um you would want political
accountability of the people who manage
them this is kind of the argument that's
given for infrastructure monopolies you
know for instance roads or electricity
that let's say we live in a country we
need one power plant the bigger the
power plant the better off we will all
be
and there's a natural monopoly in the
power plant business so we're going to
have to have one power plant and this is
only one power plant then we can't just
let anybody
own it because then they're going to
make it too expensive so we need to have
the government own it so it can make it
too expensive and you don't find that
case compelling not at all i used to
believe in it i was pretty much a
keynesian when i first started my
graduate studies at colombia
and no i don't find that compelling at
all because i think all these examples
that they mention of natural monopolies
or economies of scale that can only fit
at a scale of government
it's always
it's always you know government bans
people from opening power plants
and then there's only one power plant
and they need to be in charge of it
but in reality
no in reality the you know power plants
can exist at all kinds of manners of
scales of operation and yes of course
there are benefits to centralization in
power plants in particular because
there's efficiency in uh generation you
know one
big power plant is more efficient than
10 equivalent smaller power plants but
there's also inefficiencies in
centralization because the more
centralized and the bigger the plant is
the further away
a lot of the
population is going to be so you're
going to be losing a lot of the
electricity and transmission
and you believe the free market is best
in managing that dance that balance of
decentralization exactly and if we do
end up in a situation where there's one
power plant for an area
then i you know if the markets
ends up centralizing all of it into one
power plant i don't see that as a
problem um there are places you know
there's a small town with only one
barber shop is that a catastrophe no
because
they don't need two barbershops now if
that barbershop started to take
advantage of people started to charge
higher price
well then that's just an opportunity for
others to step in and put them in their
place and that's the same thing with
power plants it's the same thing with
everything
um ultimately
i think the key thing is this
from the central planning perspective
they'll present you the problem as it is
and they'll tell you well this is bad so
the fix you know and and what we can do
is better so let's stop what's bad
and do what is better
two problems here usually the reason
that the thing is bad in the first place
is because it is a government monopoly
is because of government intervention
but the second thing is that this notion
that we could just pass a law and fix
what's wrong and make it better
is
it ignores the fundamental underlying
reality which is that what you're doing
is you're offering only one way for this
problem to be solved and making all
other solutions practically illegal
you're taking taxpayer money you're
putting guns to people's heads to take
their money to use it to build say this
one solution for a power plant but
you're preventing the free market
process from providing us with other
alternatives well so you phrased it sort
of from that perspective but there in
theory there is a feedback
accountability mechanism for the
solution that you propose and enforce
by as you're saying placing a gun to
people's head
you're accountable for the uh for that
choice for the quality of that solution
by being voted out
if you if the solution is actually bad
so it's just a different selection
mechanism
and i think i personally believe it is a
selection mechanism that has worked in
the past it just often does not work
and nearly as well as a free market and
the question is are there domains
in which the free market gets itself
into trouble so this
theoretical view is that
that's the point of a free market is it
doesn't if there's trouble
that's a signal and it will respond to
that signal and it will respond
appropriately to make you try to
maximize happiness the question is is
there a local optima that free markets
get stuck in and you need governments
to represent the broader scale of the
people you get well here inside of that
i think the fundamental problem here is
the idea that there is a feedback
mechanism when there is coercion in one
party when one party can employ coercion
and the other one cannot so in other
words i'm gonna put a gun to your head
i'm gonna take your money and i'm gonna
use it to buy more guns for me to put
against your head
but somehow you're gonna put a paper in
a box and that's going to deactivate my
guns
well love requires a push and pull a
little bit of tension a little spice in
a relationship i think uh yeah i mean uh
hello gun to the headness and good luck
to anybody who's going to be dating you
if you think you're putting a gun to
people's head as comparable to a
relationship uh
all jokes but yes i mean the people
don't often think of it as gun to the as
government and the military
as
gun to the head
um but that is sort of a libertarian
perspective because ultimately when you
you know turtles all the way down and at
the bottom there's guns
yeah so bottom if you don't want to pay
if you don't want to you know all right
i don't want to be part of your power
plant i want to get my own generator i
don't want to do it i don't want to pay
for it i go to jail you can't not pay
for it that's really the asymmetry which
the market doesn't have which is why
in my opinion it's not as if you know
i'm being stubborn and stuck on the idea
that i want a market and that the
government can't work it's presented as
if you know we're choosing between two
different machines you know should we
use an apple or a pc and i'm just
constantly choosing one of them and
saying that the other one can't work
it's not equivalent it's not two
machines we're comparing between
a machine and a gun to the head and
we're comparing between a situation in
which anybody anywhere is free to
provide the service or the good and
anybody anywhere is free to buy it from
them or reject to buy it from them so
anyone can build the power plant anyone
can succeed that anybody can fail at it
anybody can build it in a way that i can
choose to take part in or not take part
in i can build my own so we have a
situation which 10 million people let's
say they each can freely choose to
provide the good or to buy the good that
cannot be considered an alternative on
an equal footing to a situation where
one person or one entity
gets to decide for everybody and those
who disagree go to jail so the problem
is
that
the alternative to governments is other
large successful entities that have
humans in them and human nature is such
that there's corruption manipulation and
so on
i think free market
depends on the
honest
communication of information
as widely as possible so people can make
great rational decisions but
sort of my fear is that like to propose
is that in general there's manipulation
whether it's government where there's
companies they're going to manipulate
they're going to try to do propaganda
they're going to try to manipulate you
deceive you uh shut down competition by
playing games human games of different
kinds
and sometimes even meaning well it's not
like everybody thinks they're doing good
and they're actually doing evil so how
do we prevent the worst of human nature
coming out
in a free market as well
by not giving the worst of human nature
a monopoly on violence in the
institution of governments that that
little inkling of coercion that little
bit of asymmetry
creates a gigantic like ripple effect of
asymmetry in your view yes and it ends
up just being the place where you know
corporations individuals free markets
they can't coerce without the resort to
government so you know you think about
all the examples of corrupt corporations
doing bad things
it's always
because they have certain privileges
from governments because you know that
as it exists you know coca-cola
mcdonald's all of these giant
corporations they can't do anything to
me without government they can't take
any of my money and they can't force me
to buy their stuff
and so
it doesn't matter to me you know so if
if coca-cola is corrupted that's a
problem for coca-cola customers that's a
problem for coca-cola shareholders
that's a problem for anybody who deals
with coca-cola but as somebody who
doesn't drink their stuff and isn't a
shareholder i have absolutely no
interest in what happens i they could
all go bust tomorrow and i don't care i
don't buy their product and i don't
and i'm not a shareholder so in this
situation where you choose to
voluntarily
associate with people and you only give
your money to people you want to
voluntarily give the money to so you
either buy their product or invest in
their production in that situation the
only way that a company can get my money
is if they build the product that they
uh that i value or if they convince me
that they are
going to use it in a way that's
profitable and they they might i may be
wrong you know i may invest in a company
that fails or i may invest in a company
that is turns out to be um
fraudulent but that's my fault you know
and
it's
it's my fault that i gave them my money
and then it turned out to be scoundrels
but it's a totally different problem
when we make it um mandatory you know
it's it's violence it's um it's a crime
to put a gun to my head and force me to
subsidize companies and forced me to
come at certain conclusions
you